[Music]
Miley Cyrus opening up like never before
as she steps back into the limelight
people don't know what happened to me
they do people would literally text me
asking I'm okay
check out Miley looking dewy and fresh
on the cover of Billboard magazine
inside the singer is getting
refreshingly real about her big
transformation rekindled romance with
Liam Hemsworth and more you make choices
and sometimes they ripen either long as
I can live - magnified 24 year old Miley
admits she's ready for a lifestyle
change
putting her risqué outfits and old
habits behind her quote I haven't smoked
weed in three weeks I'm not doing drugs
I'm not drinking I'm completely clean
right now I came in and the wrecking
ball singer has new music on the way a
love song titled Malibu written about
her on-again fiance Liam Miley also
gives candid for the first time about
from split from the Australian actor in
2013 quote I needed to change so much
and changing with someone else not
changing like that is too hard
we had to reef all for each other on
like the luckiest ever
you
[Music]